So we can see from this quiz that equations with two variables are really
powerful tools. However, not all variables that are connected, are connected in
the same way. For example, some situations will involve cause and effect, but
not all of them will. So bottom line, we need to think critically about the
quantities we're dealing with, when we're forming equations, to figure out how
we should connect the different variables that are involved. Remember that we
can often represent quantities in the real world with variables and then connect
these with equations. In these two situations that we just considered concerning
Athena's afternoon, we saw that there was a relationship of dependence between
the two things that we could express with variables. The number of sodas that
came out of the machine depended on the amount of money that Athena put into it.
And the distance she driven along the road depended on the amount of time she
spent driving. In both of these cases the value of one variable helps determine
the value of another variable. So one way we could describe what dependence
means in the case of algebra at least, is that in an equation that involves
dependence, the value of one of the variables helps determine the value of
another variable. Now a couple of other situations that involve dependence
between quantities surfaced during Athena's trip. Athena used the gas pedal
while she was driving, and when she got to her brother's house she tossed him a
can of soda. Now for each of these two new situations, please tell me which of
the sentences below, probably describes the situation involving dependents.